recording care because that setup
dynamic entertaining subscribe I don't
know hi guys great public here did not
know now you know you like the
difference now even new thing that we're
doing on this channel which is something
a lot of people do on their channels but
I'm now getting in that game jumping on
your bandwagon real hard I don't care
for any room for me I'm going to force
my way in with consent so we know how to
name for this segment right surprise
surprise it's a bunch of stuff is the
temporary name for this segment if you
guys have a suggestion for the name of
the segment leave in the comments down
below
it's a Glee Dan went online and ordered
a bunch of random Amazon products I
don't know what they are and I'm going
to open them and try to figure out and
contact clues and my intuition what
these are used for Amazon Prime okay
I seen this product before simply
straight insert all the jobs of my
younger brother in high school now he
thought it was simply straight our first
product is the brush that straightens
hair excavation point a ramage
straightening brush like I've seen
kollene use this in a video before if we
straight hair fast and easy to want
quality results great for all hair types
fast safe and gentle-like a good tinder
date feels like it's been opened and
repackaged
that's always a good sign wow that has
some girth to it has not mmm
curly ish today but I could use brushing
let's do it
starting smell a little bit like burning
so I think we're getting close on her
I'm feeling risky let's go for it does
the hold close to your roots
this is hot scented with just fresh cow
entertaining listen this is what you
came here for excellent result
look how simply straighted it kind of
soft before I like burn myself and
before Wendy actually shows up like the
kool-aid man in person
Dora is like don't touch your benches oh
no we got an electronic yodeling pickle
whatever modern woman needs in this day
and age warning choking hazard
[Music]
it's love false advertisement because
this led me to believe it would have a
face on it it does not why why why so
I'm thinking those are buzzin open their
mouths like mouth
it sounds great it does sound like when
sacani yeah yeah member this is probably
what they samples for wounded up I'm
glad we own this now all right yodeling
pickle welcome to our office enjoy your
time I what else we got oh my god
we have dancing with Jesus a hologram
[ __ ] is it picking up the dancing cuz he
is really going for it on the front of
this book Jesus is getting down
carpenter clog in the Temptation tango
there they are
let surfaced lurch you know this is
probably closer to Halloween maybe you
want to break this one out Judas hustle
oh there they all are
that's nothing okay let me pick one to
try and do I mean the cheeks turn seems
like he's having a great time stand with
your feet slightly apart twist your hips
and play in double-time twice as fast as
two solid beat turn the toe of one foot
outwards and in bring back the first
foot then do the same with the second
keep alternating step from one foot to
the other repeat at the end of the first
sequence reach out and pretend slap your
partner the end got a little weird I
feel like it's like this am i doing it
every day flat you just have an as
divine of an experience as I did fixing
it flag for too much religion one more
oh you know I own one of these already
there she is
this is not the world's most complicated
build oh oh this is the body back buddy
trigger point massage retriever warning
I actually have this at home I do I own
this already it's not subtle but neither
is chronic back pain
just sort of use it to roll out
different muscle groups on your back and
it's like sort of works I guess this
model seems to have had some head trauma
before she started using the back buddy
Wow oh you can get your under but get a
girl oh don't worry guys there's a body
back buddy jr. this doesn't fit in your
carry-on bag do not allow children to
use the body back buddy as a toy this is
not a toy but this is for this episode
of surprise it's a bunch of stuff I'm
going to say my least favorite look mate
I may have to go with the brush mostly
because I'm too afraid to use it
actually on my hair and so brushes least
favorite and I'm going body back buddy
I mean it's practical and all this is a
little large and awkward but I don't
really second place Dancing with Jesus I
mean it would have been first Pat Durban
I guess like video tutorials I think
it's a little difficult understand the
steps just in print and then number one
obviously all damn day just more more
beautiful each time I play it thank you
guys for watching this episode of
surprised um there's much stuff you guys
want this stuff let's do that
because we already naive' gotten my wear
out of most of the products you know I
mean I'm on the fence on giving you this
guy but if you guys want this stuff
maybe we do monthly giveaways and which
one of you will win the surprise that
there's a bunch of stuff any bags have
suggestions on things that we can check
out make sure you leave in the comments
down below and don't forget to click
this button subscribe to this YouTube
channel and we'll see you next time with
more stuff I don't know like if you're
really bummed that you didn't win like
the my life is a the macbook pro
giveaway don't worry I got you covered
I'm also very generous